we have a voicemail number which is two
one nine two david p this is a really
interesting question there has not been
a lot of discussion about Bernie Sanders
being Jewish as a as one of the leading
twenty twenty Democratic primary
candidates I got a voicemail from a
viewer that has a question about this
and it's actually very interesting on a
couple of different levels take a listen
to this
hey David mile this is Steve from Los
Angeles I want your opinion on something
I'm a Bernie supporter but you know I'm
I I'm also Jewish and I and I even
afraid that if he's elected that that
and something goes wrong as something
might for example recession
it'll be blamed on Jews and you know
people are am I being too paranoid I
know your viewers do you think about
that possibility yeah I'm interested in
your opinion I'm thinking of switching
my support to Elizabeth Warren and
they'll be blamed on women no just
kidding um but no I'm serious people get
crazy and I don't want to exacerbate
latent anti-semitism so if we could have
two same thing the same Paula similar
policies with with the Elizabeth Warren
I think I prefer that what do you think
yeah here's what you have to understand
whether or not bernie is President stuff
is already all getting blamed on Jews I
mean listen you go back to the Iraq war
of 2003 and those who have the tendency
to want to blame Jews say the real
culprits of the 2003 Iraq war are Jews
because you know Paul Wolfowitz worked
for George W Bush and Donald Rumsfeld
I think his Jewish worked for George W
Bush and so the Jews are to blame for
the 2003 Iraq war you go to Latin 9/11
conspiracy theories Jews Israel slash
the Mossad for people who have these
tendencies are they are they are blaming
the Jews so yes you are right if Bernie
is president and things don't go well it
will be blamed on the Jews but the Jews
are blamed anyway and what you have to
understand is that with Bernie being
Jewish sure
winning the nomination if it were to
happen will be attributed to
conspiratorial crafty Jews working
together this is to be expected it's not
a good reason not to support Bernie if
that is who most aligns with your
political views the Jews have been
blamed for everything under the Sun for
thousands of years by the conspiracists
and that's going to continue
whether Bernie Sanders is the president
or not those who cede you if all you
have is a hammer everything looks like a
nail I think is the way the phrase goes
and if you consider Jews as people I've
interviewed sometimes consider if you
consider the Jews to be the problematic
group the harbingers of negative
consequences etc then any problem that
you identify with society you are going
to blame on them no matter who is
president of the United States so yes
you're right Bernie Sanders will
certainly receive criticism on the basis
of anti-semitism and blaming Jews for
everything but that exists anyway and I
would just vote for whoever most aligns
with your policy ideas we've got a great
bonus show today we are going to talk
about we've not talked much about the
Central Park five in its connection to
Donald Trump on the regular show we are
going to talk about that on the bonus
show today we will also talk about
Domino's Pizza starting to deliver
pizzas via autonomous robot this year
and I will still not order Domino's
pizza but that's not the main focus of
the story and then we will also talk
about the situation involving
conservative Kyle Kossuth and Harvard
rescinding its admission offer to him I
actually met Kyle at politican in
October of 2018 and we will talk about
that on the bonus show as well two ways
to get instant and permanent access to
the bonus show become a member at WWJ
pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show